greetings from podcast Ville you filthy
animals this podcast is brought to you
by blue apron the leading milk it
delivery service in the United States
and while many people know what we do
many don't know what types of meals you
could eat when you cook with blue apron
ooh a please delivers fresh pre
proportion ingredients and step-by-step
recipes right to your door that can be
cooked in 45 minutes the menu changes
every week based on what's in season and
customers can pick two three or four
recipes best and what fits their
schedule now I'm gonna do blue apron
we're gonna take care of the family
you're gonna get $30 off your first
order when you visit blue apron comm
slash Joey again that's blue apron comm
slash Joey check out this week's menu
and get $30 off blue apron comm slash
Joey blue apron a better way that cook
now unless you live in another [ __ ]
cave unless you live in a [ __ ] cave
you don't know what's going on this
weekend well let me tell you what's
going on this weekend everybody's
worried about North Koreans sending
missiles and this guy in the Russians
and who gives a [ __ ] this weekend to
[ __ ] powerhouse states are gonna go up
against each other and that's in New
England [ __ ] Patriots aka Boston
against Philadelphia aka what's
Philadelphia Pennsylvania
okay these are two u.s. powerhouses you
understand me and this is how we make
[ __ ] money who you're thinking of
getting paid this weekend is the way
you're gonna get paid the big game is
here and it's time to cash in big and
bet the game with my bookie dot AG if
you haven't checked them out this is the
[ __ ] weekend to get into the
action have a hunter who's gonna win the
coin toss or what color the Gatorade the
winning coach gonna be wearing log on
now check out the props and get it on
the [ __ ] action don't just watch the
game lay some gave us down invite some
hookers over to get your pipes up and
watch the [ __ ] money grow
join me and thousands of our online
players and start betting on my bookie
da de Jean I'll join
now today right now let's get the party
started what [ __ ] around you're gonna
score free cash to play super bowl wager
on the house right now my bookies givin
away up to $1,000 to every new player
all right you understand me sign up
today to score an instance 50% bonus and
your first deposit that's right if you
join with a yardstick that's on offer
you Gentiles you get a 150 to play with
use promo code Church CH you are CH to
activate this offer that's right that's
how uncle Joey roasts okay turn it over
to your little [ __ ] girlfriend have a
picture see if you're [ __ ] dreamin you
give me a yardstick I'm gonna give you
150 to play with there right use promo
code Church to activate the office and
most importantly you play you win you
get paid and that's what it's all [ __ ]
about take that [ __ ] meal leave I
won't even talk over [ __ ] to park that
drop is so [ __ ] good welcome to the
Church of what's happened now happy
Monday
that's it January's over you're still in
the same [ __ ] predicament it's your
[ __ ] dilemma we're gonna help you out
today I get my main man brother
agent mentor my man Gordon Warnock and
is usually the Christ killer with his
little coke shirt on [ __ ] supporting
their anti war effort and hit them who
gives a [ __ ] how you doing buddy
everybody good
everybody have a good weekend oh yeah
it's beat up what's better than loving
especially when it's cold on the East
Coast
[ __ ] 87 like that today and you over
there we're in a [ __ ] penguin suit
what I'm saying thinking about shoveling
the ice off your [ __ ] Anik anyway if
you came to the shows at the comedy zone
in Charlotte I thank you there were five
great shows you guys were sensational
audiences I want to thank the green guy
with the green hair who gave me those
[ __ ] THC lollipops I was [ __ ] up
the first night and on the fly at home I
was kind of [ __ ] up myself and I said
I had a good weekend Charlotte so I love
you thank you very much for making me
feel at all that's it brother what's
going on let me open up the door it's a
little [ __ ] wall man here hold up
yeah that's crazy about Charlotte it's
uh it's been pretty cool cuz the last
couple times like I I went to Austin
with you
at school guiding they see the other
people show up from the podcast it's
really cool to have a full show well
it's it's been a family it's like been
to these [ __ ] family
Thursday night was a lot of church I
think Friday early which I mean they all
come out man and I oh my heart for
coming out that's it so what's up with
Eugene money that's it man just out here
spend some time seeing a family and
taking care of some [ __ ] it's uh it's
been a good trip
good Gordon uh for those who don't know
is my agent aka mentor in the writing
world we've been talking for years now
you know in Florentine was on here last
week I said I wanted thinking to write
the book it was three years if I don't
feel that [ __ ] bad it's a child
everything so he was in town I figured
I'd get him on here maybe you people
want to write a book you have
aspirations of being a writer and I
think Gordon to open up your eyes and a
lot of different avenues and stuff like
that cuz it's it it's a really
interesting thing to do I never I wrote
Tommy fears that's great you're right
comedy and then years ago I started
putting on a story a week on MySpace and
it was [ __ ] the hardest thing I ever
had to do and it's like I tell people
all the time did you go to Samuel French
I did I got you know I got the book the
day it came out the newer the new one
I'm so exciting us yeah well he got a
book for commercial agents and whatnot
but when you went to Sam your friends oh
it's crazy how many books are in them
right now is it right you know what I
the right you know what I got a couple
of the books I got a book on acting for
TV commercials and I got a book of
because a couple people told me to try
writing TV so I bought a book of
Seinfeld scripts just to see what like a
good one would look like like alright
let's see what it was written they had
they had plays there I spent like 30
minutes there was awesome if you ever go
into a store guys and you ski and you
see a script for one of your favorite
movies or a movie that you watched a few
times and they wanted to ten buck bucks
buy it take it home and read the script
to see how it different that was like
the original draft yeah yeah and then
you see the movie it's pretty [ __ ]
interesting how it changes from the
original draft because when you get it
you don't you don't know what drafted is
were you buying on the [ __ ] like I
bought Goodfellas yeah and the Godfather
on the road and Toronto they're really
great store yeah they have a store they
just sell scripts that's so cool
every [ __ ] movie you want well I
didn't note I got home I put together on
my own
then it's the revisions that you that's
why the film is different than the
script yeah and sometimes they'll do
that too without alone they'll publish a
whole book that is just about that movie
and the script and all the notes and
photos behind the scenes and all that
kind of [ __ ] and it's like it shows you
more than you get from just the page it
shows how that movie came about there
was one from the Godfather just came out
a couple years ago and a few others out
there if there's a movie out there
you're really interested in yeah getting
the script yeah pretty [ __ ] rad to
read it and go wow I didn't see this
scene in the movie and then you'll see
it somewhere else in the script I moved
it so if I wanted to be a writer like
how many books did you see I'm writing
Lily oh my god
Jesus Christ it was cool because I'm in
Gordon so you work mainly in books yeah
okay so yeah like that's they have stuff
on that but then they had stuff I'm
writing plays they had stuff like yeah
TV shows films you know just be coming
right and when I first got here like
anybody else I lived in Samuel French I
really enjoyed the place yeah
there's no have you been to them I don't
know if you maybe on the way home stop
and you don't have a ton of traffic I'll
shoot over lo Daniel look a left yeah
okay parking the only person working you
have parking and just it's a half hour
experience yeah and you know what the
funny thing is they're all scams like I
used to get going in spend 100 by
shoplift 50 yeah right because they
strap the labels at the door late when
you go to pay they have labels so when
you come to this town the biggest thing
is getting representation so you go to
Samuel French and you buy a book that
comes out quarterly and it's called the
agents or the guide to commercial agents
yeah they have those four books right if
you go to page three you break it down
each commercial agent will
tell you what they're looking for
hypnotist jugglers a guy with one eye a
guy with missing limbs I mean they don't
put it that way but another one it tells
you what they're what they represent it
represents stand-up comics you know then
when they put stand-up comics it's very
general that means that that means you
to be a improv comic a staying at our
iconic or clean dozen and that's why
totally into if you live in LA you might
as well go out for commercials because
they're right in front of you yeah it's
a ride and you get to meet other people
you mingle when you get to see people
that now go in for the same class as you
they fit everything you'll go in Forli
you see the same people that and now
you'll see the commercial on air right
so now you know he booked it and now
next time you see him at the commercial
with you
you start getting [ __ ] dirty looking
[ __ ] you know it's but you say hi man
nice to see you great luck good luck on
the camera the great so it's kind of
weird when you see the finished product
and what they were looking for yeah and
it's it's weird for a guy like me
because I moved here working in
post-production I had no at all no
thoughts of acting and everyone I talked
to oh it's not like they're not mad at
me but everyone I talk to is like you're
gonna book at least two or three things
right away cuz I don't you don't even
want him yeah because he doesn't know
what he's doing
one two he doesn't need it he doesn't
want it and three you know it's it's I
mean he's gonna get pissed off
eventually some commercial auditions you
gone and they're running an hour behind
and you gotta walk back to the meter and
put a quarter in it yeah and you're most
of them on Santa Monica the fifth Street
and they've all want to see they always
want to see your age group at 4:45 all
right that's why when that guy won the
Oscar he said by the way I went to every
audition
even in Santa Monica at 5 o'clock
because people [ __ ] hate those that's
well known I can't imagine going back to
Samuel French when you go to Samuel
French guys over the years my first five
years here I love to lie to you
I lived on couch and I spent fifty
percent of my money on books of Samuel
French the other 50% on cocaine and if I
know what I know now I was
100% on cocaine cuz those books you get
so caught up and reading them that you
don't write yeah you keep thinking that
the more books you read it's gonna come
to you one day the Hemingway ISM yeah
right yeah well it helps to educate
yourself like that and get some of those
books and realize what's important to
them to the folks who are ultimately
looking to sign you or buy whatever your
you're trying to sell but at the same
time and you got to be an artist to you
know you can't be a hundred percent
scientific about it you know it's you
just got to have soul to it you know
it's weird that okay so I want to be a
writer I'm write for the school
newspaper in high school I do the sports
section what's my next move George
Gordon what depends on what kind of
writer you want to be if you want to be
a sports book writer then you got to
keep write infrared sports publications
write articles things like that if you
want to be a novelist if you want to
come up with your fantasy novel or
whatever then you got to start you know
working on your craft start reading you
know what other fantasy books are out
there that people are buying and see
what they do and kind of you know read
them with a pen in hand and see how they
put this book together and and then it's
just it's what you've been doing man
it's it's writing and rewriting and you
know throwing that away and rewriting
and just it's a process but you know it
goes through over and over again with
you and then you send it to people and
they help you edit and all sorts of you
know back and forth with the agent with
the publisher and by the time it it
spits out as a book you know it might be
very different from what you started but
it'll still be something that you know
hopefully if if you still believe in
that story and really want to get it out
then it's something that is you're gonna
celebrate somebody like Nick tuturro
yeah who's a Yankee fan who knows every
fact about the Yankees he writes and
let's say he writes an article to you
and he goes Gordon I'm having a tough
time making money is there any way I can
write an article for somebody how does
that process go somebody just wants to
write articles for like Muscle & Fitness
or
somebody is an expert in whatever their
field is or not even an expert yeah
you've done it for 15 [ __ ] years you
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
you know there's a trade magazine that
you've been reading 50% of it is
[ __ ]
you know what Gordon before I became
electrical contact tractor I went to
school for four years and I took
creative writing yeah I've written some
articles I sent them to you
they're not bad pieces of right you know
maybe he could use some help
how do you go about getting a job in
those situations like well those are a
lot of just kind of being on top of what
you what you're writing into like the
types of magazines that you're
submitting to you need to also read
those and make sure that you're not
sending something that's you know too
long or meanders off topic or whatever
works you need to make sure that it's
it's that specific style writing for say
Sports Illustrated versus ESPN magazine
you know you kind of tailor it toward
that magazines aesthetic and and from
there I mean it's a lot of lot of
committing a lot of a lot of work you
don't usually need an agent for these
kinds of you know magazines and stuff
like that it doesn't hurt but you don't
need to have someone sending in on your
behalf when it gets the book world
that's a little bit different but when
if you just want to write if we get yeah
yeah it's freelance you want to be a
freelance sports journalist or whatever
and then that's that's something that
you do and you start small you start
local you start writing you know sports
articles for your local newspaper or
what have you and then you build up a
resume and from there you kind of you
know keep going steps up until you get
to to the big leagues now they're
writing colleges Lee and I were talking
about a friend of mine we're talking
about a Syracuse USC Emerson has a huge
Emerson yeah you know that you go to
college and you [ __ ] come out of here
because most of the agents I've had have
either gone to Syracuse University Miami
ever since you know they were all the
same now who are the writing Colella
saman [ __ ] in high school I'm not
thinking about writing a [ __ ] book
like the kid I grew up with he's a nice
kid he wrote for the paper all his life
but since that guy Cinderella man yeah
what was his name since that guy grew up
in our hometown he co-wrote the book
that eventually was the movie that was
made and he's sold the ride whatever I
don't know what the [ __ ] he did but he
was just a regular sports writer like in
oh yeah Jenna and then the Hudson County
paper I forget what his [ __ ] name is
I I spoke to him about two weeks ago the
um but Cinderella man grew up in North
Bergen so the box are here the boxes
Brian and James Braddock I mean Hudson
County Park is Braddock Park yeah so we
all knew little bit I didn't know all
that stuff about him but even he went he
made the transition well you know what
happened he knew the knowledge somebody
else was the writer they got together
they co-wrote the book yeah that happens
a lot something that I've been it
doesn't it doesn't have to be writing
but something I've struggled with and
it's it seems like something you must
deal with on a daily basis is people who
are writing submitting stuff do you want
it to be perfect
wanted to be almost be like a finished
draft rather than like a rough draft
it's like how do you deal with coaxing
someone through like almost like to get
past their perfection my perfectionism
like that part well you do need a
certain amount of Drive and
perfectionism to but at a certain part
you got it you got to send it out right
you can't sit on it forever and ever and
keep making little tweaks and you
eventually do have to let go and kind of
be able to you know let it leave the
nest so to speak but you know how
harvests and that work
yes the idea was how hard it is for me
to send you something after I keep
reading it and reading it and reading
and then you find the missing word but
it's it's it's it never ends it's yeah
but now sometimes I read a book and I
see a [ __ ] up world look you know that
happens and no matter how many people
they take go through and take a look at
it you're going to have some typos and
finished products but that's that's the
number one thing that whenever we have a
phone call I always tell you man don't
worry about making it perfect you know
just get it out of your soul and onto
the page and then we're gonna work with
it from there and we're gonna edit and
make it better and then you know
publishers gonna do the same thing so
for you it's it's mostly a process of
just you know taking your heart out and
putting it onto the piece of paper and
then from there we go back and forth and
cut it up and on't rest of it but it's
yeah it's a process the worst is one
like this last chapter I wrote like I
did great with the other chapter I
outlined it in this chapter I outlined
the kidnapping this is the one after I
turned myself in the day after the
kidnapping and I outlined it I ended up
it it started off with the state of mind
which I always like to include and
they're like what was I going through
and then I told you too much information
once I looked at it it was finished then
I go I'm not sending this out this
middle piece I do not like this middle
piece because it kind of went into three
different stories that I was missing the
whole story they got to help me out you
know it was like the last person in the
[ __ ] world like I hear I was beating
the wrong bushes and Austin I got a call
they're like yeah my father wants to
talk to you he just wants to come down
and visit with you and I was like I
don't think it's a good idea he goes I
think it's a good idea and he came down
and asked me what I had done and he
[ __ ] bailed me out
like Jesus and it's like I was telling
me you know when you get out of one of
those situations I can't imagine getting
louder than the same asylum like let's
save you go crazy one night maybe punch
in there for 60 days
because the feelings you get when you
walk out of there you think everybody is
watching you everywhere I went for two
or three weeks I had this stink on me
that everybody had known what I had done
and I didn't make eye contact I would go
to the supermarket hit it out and talk
to the butcher anymore and it took me
three weeks to you know so it's really
hard that was what I wanted to get on
paper yeah but that's not what [ __ ]
came out on [ __ ] paper because I get
high sometimes I ran at night my best
writing is in the daytime right yeah
sometimes I get so bored at nine o'clock
at night I go let me give it a shot yeah
I get good I get two hours into
something and the next morning I wake up
and I go what the [ __ ] is this
I gotta stick to my mind am taemin 10:10
a.m. writing you know well the most
important part is actually doing the
writing whether or not it ends up that's
it that's it yeah
that's the muscle that they don't tell
you any of the books yeah that you're
not gonna get a perfect first time and
that's okay that's that that all you
need to do is keep writing yeah just
it's just like the thing I say about
keeps showing up yeah you're sad [ __ ]
you go to gym eventually it all clicks
keep it with Joey I went to the gym like
gained four pounds that's okay that's
right now well if you keep going it's
gonna twist in your mind you'll twist
your mind that why are you killing
yourself to be a fat [ __ ] and all sudden
you'll start looking at your diet but
it'll all start somewhere yeah it has to
start with not potential energy but
kinetic energy energy in motion well
that's my question for you Joe cuz that
I know you were to blog before you
started doing this but like that's
something that I bought if you want it
to be perfect so you don't even start
like how long did it take you to start
trying to write the book my problem with
the book was and with anything I do I
double question myself right okay I'm a
human being I bleed just like everybody
else
and I have been securities like
everybody else you start double guessing
yourself at every level I don't have
that's my biggest [ __ ] problem in
this whole [ __ ] thing whether it's
Fitness that's always been my biggest
problem a problem yes but also you know
that's kind of what makes you good at
what you do what you do artists I found
are way more introspective than the
average person and so that could be a
good thing help them come up with some
really good stuff but it could also be a
little aggravating kills yeah I don't
know kills me guys
that's what I've been working a lot with
my therapist on just noticing my
patterns in life what I've done for 29
years how the situation's changed but my
reactions really don't and whether it's
school work and I have to like I'm in
the process of trying to kick myself
like just in just do something like this
is off topic of books but there's this
gut this vlogger and Casey nice that
he's a great has millions of followers
sold the app to CNN a couple years ago
for millions CNN just closed it he's
back to vlogging and some people looked
at that as a failure which it it did
fail a little bit but he still made
millions he like he still had that so
like just seeing that really like it was
like wait there's no [ __ ] failure
there that's the [ __ ] thing that what
finally got me going with you with the
book was ah yeah this guy's the sweetest
kind of world he believes me but I don't
believe with me he telling me the
stories right there right at Joey every
year I would write three paragraphs and
go he's not gonna like this and I just
said enough is enough this book isn't
gonna write itself
nothing writes down on itself you know
yeah that's the thing about the arts
karate jujitsu riding stand up along the
way you get to find out about your
faults and that's the biggest [ __ ]
hurdles that kills you the most to
accept these faults and try to read or
or to keep falling into that trap that's
what happens as an artist or that's what
I'm a criminal I don't know about the
art what I'm trying to tell you is that
that's your
biggest rap yeah it's always it it
always has been from me well it's always
there but it's it's also you know again
it's beneficial because you have a whole
bunch of people who it's their job to
kind of tell you what your faults are
and through their help you kind of you
know become a better writer yes but then
that that one product that you're trying
to get out also gets polished up and and
and good to go and and I mean you have a
lot of people pointing out a lot of
faults before something comes out and
you know it's all it's all for the best
but people pointing out a fault and you
finding a fault
well that's it's two different
observation yeah it really is when you
find the fault and you attack it some
people I attack it
you know I knock it like today I call
doc I gotta go for this tetanus shot I
recant only once literally go for the
tetanus shot and they're gonna draw
blood the same day that's a double
whammy I'm not going down either one
street or one bad street you know I
won't let you flat yeah I get the same
thing man hits from muscular needles or
the ones that freak me the [ __ ] out cuz
I could feel the serum going into the
[ __ ] thing yeah I faint three years
ago from an ass shot didn't even see the
needle I just bent over and never bent
back up I just stayed that they kept
tapping me okay and okay I was [ __ ]
pale but so okay so now I'm in high
school I want to be a [ __ ] writer
what college do I go to what type of
courses do I think if you want to work
with a specific writer a lot of writers
like literary writers are also
professors like one of my favorite
authors
Lancel sand works out at the University
of Utah and so if you write works like
him and you want to learn from him then
you apply there
or I mean Brown is another really big
one that's very exclusive Iowa is
another one I heard about that one yeah
yeah oftentimes you'll see like when
their industry announcements of an
author gets signed or a book gets sold
they'll say oh they worked on this at
Iowa and then you know that you know
it's really gotten a close eye
but it's not so much the the schooling
and the education is what you get out of
it I've read some work from students at
Brown it was a complete [ __ ] and some
you know go on to become really well
published successful authors you know
it's what you do with it rather than
just what school you go to or whatever I
mean I know plenty of people who went to
stay at schools or didn't even go to
college you you know have book deals and
have writing careers it's you have to
have that Drive how similar to stand up
how do writers get their work critiqued
when they're not getting it purchased
like how do you how do you like okay
well this is I because I'm sure they
don't send it back to you hey we didn't
buy it and this is why we didn't buy it
they probably just say no thank you
yeah yeah we can't really give detailed
feedback usually just because of the
volume that comes in is just crazy but
it's you know you have to work on it and
revise it and do as well as you can and
then you have to show it to other
peoples so it helps to have a critique
group or a writing partner or someone
who you you share work back and forth
and you kind of mark it up and say well
this is I was confused at this point or
this character probably needs something
else here they are a fresh set of eyes
that look over your work for you and
that's the kind of working out process
of you know you going up on stage doing
open mics are doing you know five minute
spots or whatever and right it's that
kind of thing and sometimes you know
they're not going to be meeting and
discussing your full manuscript it'll
oftentimes be at ten pages or a chapter
or whatever that they'll still trade and
then meet up a week later and sometimes
that's you know that's how you work it
out and it must be because I know Joey's
worked with a few people and like for me
I when you told me about the peer group
yeah I started thinking about about
school and how much I hated give me my
writing other people especially if I
didn't like them I was like you know I
don't care what you think about my
writing so it must be pretty it like
that must be an important part of it is
finding the right people to work with
because like if you send it to someone
and you hate their a painting you're
like well that doesn't I'm not gonna
think you learn anything here and you
got to find the right people to I mean
if you find someone who doesn't know
what they're talking about or
there you know not your kind of writer
they just don't know your genre then
it's going to be you know detrimental
even getting bad advice is worse than
getting no advice at all so like I know
the style of writing that I like watch
as I open up a book yeah like a lot the
last 10 years or so writing has gone
into this avant-gardes that's too many
words even what you trying to [ __ ]
tell me
yeah too many words for what the [ __ ]
you're trying to tell me I'm very happy
that you're intelligent and I'm very
happy if you're insightful but it's too
much guy just like you know people send
me books all the time and those are the
books I read everything I try to read
everything and like I you know my
favorite authors obviously are Hemingway
and Stephen King yeah I love the the
process of somebody scaring the [ __ ] out
of me on paper you know without even
talking to you as soon as you open up
Kujo you're scared you know that's the
first even King I book I read in prison
you know I did that's the first book I
read and I reading harm books and
prisons because it wouldn't think so red
flag hold on what do you think I got a
bunch of double in there and you still
here in there with your credit card and
go can I have to work so [ __ ] it now
they have a car a black guy comes up to
you with six books three of them or
basketball
two of them are criminals and the other
ones about world war [ __ ] one you got
a choice make one pana yeah and one of
the other books I read that was a very
enjoyable was on wings of eagles
it was the pseudo biography of to do
with the big ears from Texas that was
ran for president her own bro yeah like
that was just another great book I read
was the sound to lambs or was weird I
used to only read books when I was a kid
that had movies attached to him because
I wanted to see and then after a while
I'm like why do I do this this is the
dumbest thing in the world to read a
book with a [ __ ] movie either watch
the movie or read the book pick up
[ __ ] country and then now I read but
it's funny like when I read Hemingway
his biography I read Hemingway his
biography when I lived
Aspen lady 3 I don't know the
neighborhood book now my book my buddy
went to brown I think he's the one that
gave it to me and the one I read it
sounded so [ __ ] insane like yeah
there was no nothing in the book that
described worked do you know who's
saying like that's what pissed me off in
hindsight like I used to see hunter s
tops Hunter s Thompson wrote some great
books but I used to copy that the Woody
Creek [ __ ] tavern once a week and I'd
see hunter s Thompson in there and from
what I heard from people he was always
in there when we [ __ ] time right
there fine time to write books everybody
was always party all the guys I liked
except Stephen King I read on writing
and yeah that's a good one yeah he
blasts music is [ __ ] oh yeah whatever in
races the window towards the [ __ ]
thing yeah it's very interesting but
except for Stephen King's biography
nothing Himba gave me the illusion of
work it was like they went we got up
wrote three sentences what's the same I
went to a bar like that's like you know
with them probably with any kind of art
but you know if you you don't know
stand-up you think that some guy just
gets up on stage and talk [ __ ] for an
hour that was Lena I thought that you
just got up on stage you said hey you
mind taping myself tonight I got some
[ __ ] the same somebody hit the course
this is gonna be good yeah but no I
always found writing to be like how I
wrote a joke for years was that have an
idea I wrote a tag for it and then I
went to a comedy store work that yeah
and that's why my career was [ __ ]
because I wasn't tagging that wasn't
really putting hard into where they're
telling a story we're telling the
listener why I have this opinion on this
subject
compared to my life I wasn't doing all
that you know yeah and then I heard a
special with a guy's joke sounded like
mine who wasn't stable or nothing it was
a type of jokes I was doing and I
realized how come he was so successful
was the same reason why I was so
accessible because our material was [ __ ]
yeah which my material I'm low
comedy writer I just tell you what's in
my heart I'd mix it a different way but
even like when I watch like to me great
comedy writers the Oh Brennan is
definitely up there right now to me
there's some people who are just
brilliant joke writers Rogen comes into
mind from time to time a Chappelle
writes a different type of joke a Yank
but it's all there voice yeah we're
talking about the same thing as when you
when you're writing you the hardest
thing to do is find your voice and that
you can only do through repetition so
like we were talking about ralfie before
the podcast said he last time he was on
here he talked about when he first
started doing stand-up it was all fat
jokes and he didn't really find his his
voice and what he was going to be
talking about and he was just going to
the easy way he's talking about his
weight and someone pulled them aside and
said hey do you want to be a fat
comedian or you want to be a comedian
who happens to be fat and so it's it's
the same kind of thing of you know
finding how you want to tell your
stories what kind of details you want to
focus on and just it's the same thing as
finding your voice but here's the funny
thing if you read Judy Carter's workbook
which I've never seen her perform so
when you read her handbook but again the
coach should have [ __ ] Chicago Bulls
was a horrible player Phil Jackson and
look what he became that's why the best
I don't believe it'll be that she would
be like wow this guy won the Nationals
or whatever I did that I like this
people were just great teachers who know
how to get it to you what we talking
with we talked about finding a voice I
think comedy writing and and wedding
books I mean it's I know that make sense
for Ralphie may not only talking about
his week Oh
so Judy Carter says that the second joke
okay the old moon print I'm sorry Leena
blueprint for comedy is that you open
with your second best joke
Joe so you Judy Carter and her workbook
says that she wants you to open with
your second best show but she wants your
second bet your second bit to be about
the most noticeable feature you have is
in high disagreement yeah a box
I wanted that at the end over the years
like I had a friend who had a glass eye
and he did comedy if you go on stage and
he would say one joke and then he
attacked the glass eye well guess what
now you got nowhere to go
yeah after the glass eye explosion with
your [ __ ] - get him that's it because
they laughed at the glass eye you know
and he would do ten minutes on you think
I'm watching you but I'm really looking
at the clock and it was all funny stuff
I kept telling Dawg you slippin yeah
that's your last five minutes you could
keep adding that like my friend Roger
Rittenhouse has a [ __ ] hook okay yeah
well Roger Rittenhouse would come on
stage
he'd address the hook but then later on
he would do the thing about that his arm
[ __ ] up one time he took it in again
my foot by mistake yeah so he had a foot
you know I don't like the noticeable
thing so there's two avenues to that so
that's when you start first of all you
have to block aids when you start you
have the blockade of if you're fat or
skinny or ugly you've got a big nose or
you're missing an eye
and you also have the blockade of
something else I was gonna tell you what
the [ __ ] is going on my memory thread
and take my alpha brain you have two
blocks oh you're doing who you admire oh
right yeah like I think I don't know if
it was you I sent you something in the
beginning and you know how that's gonna
work because I was trying to be Stephen
King well you were you were you said
something about you know I'm no
Hemingway where I said you know good
I don't want Hemingway I want your DN so
yeah it's um you know yes you're going
to pick up some tendencies from some
authors and and sometimes you'll hear
some advice
in writing books that it's common to say
oh don't use adverbs they're weak words
well they are weak words but sometimes
you need a little connective tissue or
sometimes you need a little dynamics
like like Dean just reshot is special
because the first one was too good his
CD taping the first one was just he said
it was at 10 the whole time and he
needed a little give-and-take and so he
just just recorded a CD because the
first one was you know crowd was too
into it
thank you smart yeah it was I'm just
going back to it like if you do you
don't want to set yourself in a hole I'm
sure but and I'm sure this happens with
writers too I've been going to open mics
and it's I enjoy seeing like there's a
guy there last night who plays poker so
he had to talk about that there's a
couple guys who are waiter so they had
jokes about so it's you even though they
don't have the joke writing experience
that Joey does it's I can tell when
they're writing a joke and when they're
actually like oh this happened today
yeah when I was working or they liked it
and then it actually you can see you
making a bigger connection with it yeah
and some of that advice that you'll hear
sometimes someone will say write what
you know and there are you know reasons
to do that and reasons to not do that
but it definitely is a source of
material when you have even if you're
writing fiction and but you know a guy
that was kind of a little certain way
that you know you want to make your
characters sort of like him you know you
you appropriate reality for what you're
making up you know whether you're
writing fiction or nonfiction your life
is going to influence that so it's going
to be you know something that will creep
out on it alright well gets a little itj
English for example we'll just draw his
name out like I discovered from 98 to
about 2004 I spent a lot of money on the
road on Barnes and Nobles I was going
with town and if the condo was close to
Barnes and Nobles I'm going there and
just destroyed a crude crowd true crime
section yeah yeah I always loved whether
it was a book on oj is something I
always was Mesmer
by those topics I read every mafia book
that had to do from 1965 up I didn't
really like the Capone air and all that
stuff and I read all of that
in honesty with you because I always
want to be prepared for those roles well
I moved here and especially after The
Sopranos I noticed I was always getting
called in yeah for mafia role so I read
those books about different guys that's
researched so I could relate a character
that guys yeah when some like last week
when I auditioned the guy's name is
taffy
I give that guy a name sir his name is
Joey
taffy Taffer Ally and I give him a
background so when I go in there I have
a certain thought in my mind to play
that guy okay let's pretend like teach
English he's a [ __ ] white little
Jewish guy from [ __ ] the Bronx that
probably grew up around and saw mafia
people but he wrote a book about the
Westies then he wrote one of the best
books I've read for me
Havana Nocturne and then now he's
writing a book about Cuban numbers he
grew up [ __ ] why he didn't learn
about Cuban numbers so how much research
goes into that like how much [ __ ]
like those that those are the things
that have like Jerry Capeci he's a crime
writer and he knows a lot of New York
pieces a lot of Gotti [ __ ] yeah they
have contacts oh sure yeah I mean a lot
of it it depends on what you're trying
to dig up but yeah you'll talk to people
and you'll you'll take notes fuel um you
know if you need to if you're writing
about France sometimes it's it's
beneficial to go and actually walk the
streets and write a book but that's what
I'm saying well yeah it's like I don't
know anything about have to [ __ ] Joe
Rogan talks about so I would never write
a book about that stuff sure he likes
Martians and
animal whether he lives in that world
yeah he lives in that world so I would
never write about some way that bi was I
wanted to write something like that for
example what happened my buddy he grew
up in North Bergen he had all the
knowledge in the world about Cinderella
bed and when they wanted to write a book
around him he wrote whatever they
consulted it they use the visit right
yeah you I always see in movies or
whenever you see a writer on a TV show
they're always like going on a police
ride-along to do just just to like put
themselves in that oh yeah that too you
know just whatever you need to to get
that first-hand knowledge you know and
and sometimes it's a it'll significantly
alter what you're trying to write you
know you find the new story or whatever
I have a author is working on a book
right now and and the more research he
does the more kind of twists off the
original path we take but it's
ultimately you know working with him and
we're making making it stronger and it's
gonna be a lot more interesting of a
book because as some of these side
streets he's gone down and and turned it
into a big you know rope that we're all
going to braid together and make this
into a really interesting book so
sometimes it works out in your favor and
sometimes you can't get distracted and
you know waste time but now comes with
the territory you know I'll avoid your
clients are they all college-educated
writers no no no I mean some are yes and
and some have you know been published in
literary magazines and stuff like that
but for the most part no they're just
people who who want to write and put in
the work and and actually get those
results and sometimes you know that will
that will come with you know having
critique groups and partners helping
them out and sometimes it's just you
know blood sweat and tears
you know Draft after draft and you know
reading doing research but but putting
the time in I've seen the process yeah
I've seen the script writing process I
know I'm living through the book writing
process and I'd left it would do well
but I hate every doesn't get stuff you
know i when i took that breather that
was the most important thing about those
five weeks to get myself in that rhythm
well people don't understand sometimes
you just got yourself into a rhythm
remember to do this second everyday you
know what if you write a paragraph is
great and if you write [ __ ] a
thousand words it's great and I read the
second book you sent me and that man the
other a thousand word add a limit that
really had me buried the only problem
was my back was starting to hurt away so
I cut it down to 500 and I break it up
into two different sessions that's so
good what's the matter Lou you got
heartburn or something no I feel good
all right you're looking at me always
you need the edibles in your [ __ ] got
that [ __ ] out of space look you know
WOB and cheese fingers oh Jesus yeah
you'll be all right
I hope I'm fine do you do you have cuz I
don't know even what what John
reconsider this with Joey Fatone a
biographer autobiographical or like
these stories but do you work a lot and
just straight fiction I do that too and
it really depends I have I don't work
with everything naturally but there are
some types of works that I gravitate
toward and memoir is one of those it's
um it's kind of an interesting
distinction that it's not straight
autobiography like the entire story of
everything that happened it's a memory
of a big change that you go through and
we're using you know events from all
over your life but it has this one
thread this one change that you're
you're going through and that is you
know that's that's what makes it a
memoir rather than like a chronicle or
an autobiography but it's sin yeah it's
I like a good story but I'm also a very
very very big fan of the biography yeah
and my thing is I always read multiples
really you'll be multiple biographies on
the same person same person just to see
oh yeah what author what was important
to him to let you know that was my take
on it for some reason like I've read
multiple biographies on Hemingway and I
read a couple books on [ __ ] my
favorite comedian of the crazy guy from
the 60s money Bruce yeah I've always
enjoyed biographies that's why I like
telling a biography I love you know I I
don't know how many biographies I read
but they just interesting appeal like I
said Rosa Rose
they're great ones out there and that's
how you even read fuckos the guy who got
a sick that his dick suck when he was
the president hella Clinton Clinton yeah
yeah it's a Texas guy tell them to put
the era as I'm sweating like a [ __ ]
I'm sweating like Michael Jackson they
can't set up with your [ __ ] dreads to
pieces did they include the Monica
Lewinsky self in the Bill Clinton
biography no this was before this I also
read when the Kennedy won the John F
Kennedy won yeah I didn't like his
father's [ __ ] bag refrain I read her
isn't that I see a Patty Hearst woman
coming out oh yeah yeah I like all that
[ __ ] you know uh I've read a lot of
sports people like jewelry servings come
from oh yeah I love that perspective
that's my big thing I've always been a
big big fan of autobiographical stuff
for some reason another so yeah and
that's one thing that you know sometimes
you know certain people like to [ __ ] on
reading rock biographies or reading
romance or something that's perceived to
be a little fluffy or a little you know
not too serious but no man the important
part is is your reading and your taking
in information and it's it's stimulating
your mind you know it's it's you know
that enough people don't read at all you
know this is and if you find something
that is your jam you know by all means
go for it it's crazy that you would
never expect this from guy like me but
I've read all my life yeah
there's something about that piece that
I love listen to music you know I'm an
only child
I love listen to music but my other
thing is a great [ __ ] book like
there's no better feeling than getting
stoned and knowing you could go on a
plane and that you're gonna be
uninterrupted yeah that's nice I got a I
figured out how to download these books
on my little [ __ ] pad yeah and I got
Nikolas crew Gloria says Jiu Jitsu book
on there yesterday was a [ __ ] five
watt we'll fly it back you could just
watch so much [ __ ] TV yeah right and
I said let me read that for a while and
read that like 30 pages and there was
growl I love being able to read I'll
interrupt it and I don't mean at a park
under a tree Sophie bragging Shakespeare
I mean like just finding a look in your
house and getting sharable I think that
is one of the great they don't and I
also felt and this is how I felt
especially after I started writing
comedy that to write you got to read
yeah absolutely why that always has
driven me crazy that I'll speak to
comics and they don't read as much as I
read I don't know why I just like to
read some [ __ ] is garbage well I mean
joy you I know you said you started
derating in prison again but like it for
me I know there's a lot of people like
me who I haven't really read on a
consistent basis since I left high
school or college I guess cuz they they
make you do it so like you kind of get
turned off to it yeah and there's some
people who love it and some people
continue to do but I'm I'm one of the
people who I haven't read it and I've
bought books and I finished a chapter
two and I just I never cracked them
again so how do you get like how do you
guys get in the rhythm and reading I was
a [ __ ] artists reader I would take a
book and read what I wanted to read for
years I did that because I
in the seventh grade had a teacher
called mr. King Wow
who would make you read a book every
[ __ ] month and you would all book
report where's your [ __ ] nightmare
you can't buy those he will ask him
questions about the book and that really
pissed me off he's on the type of guy
that if I'm coming to a chapter and it's
got nothing to do what I'm thinking
about
I'll [ __ ] not read that chapter and
somewhere along the line I think well I
quit high school it [ __ ] me up so much
mentally yeah it really did like deep
rooted because I didn't made me feel
what I didn't want to feel growing up
which was just plain [ __ ] stupid like
it was bad enough I got left back but
now I got to quit high school and come
up and I didn't really anything in a job
that was a story I made up began well
this book go can have a certain
lifestyle which it still didn't but the
point is that that's when I got into
reading right that I stolen one of the
books I read Jimmy Piersall fear strikes
out about a Boston Red Sox player that
was crazy
and he's what we used to run around the
games the bases backwards and [ __ ]
really and he ended up in a padded room
and you know I remember all these little
books yeah I'm not one of these guys
that is gonna read a book and put up a
shelf behind me so when you come over
you gonna see them can see your display
needs you know I have favorite books
that have I've kept just because I'll
read a book over and once in a while
yeah yeah I'll do that every two or
three years just to get the teller sent
and you pick some up in it oh sure yeah
how does somebody get signed so somebody
goes to college they graduate college
they get a degree in creative writing
one of the other writings journalistic
literature any kind of so when they get
a little true already when you're in
college you should if you're in a
writing program you should already have
a [ __ ] book up by the time you go to
college now that that's asking a lot but
you're gonna learn a lot in college and
then you're going to learn even more
after you graduate and you're trying to
to write and sell books for a living you
know it's it's a tough gig you know and
and a lot of people a lot of really
famous writers too
have three four manuscripts in the
drawer that nobody's ever gonna see
because they had to do those three
before they could write one that was
good enough to sell why now they're you
know major bestsellers and stuff like
that so I mean it's it's a process of
just repetition and and you know
building up that muscle and I know
there's a lot of people who are in
college right now who listen to this and
even though you're you are still
learning yeah the thing that one of the
things that blew me away coming from
college was even though how I thought I
was really busy how much free time I
actually had in college so Joey's right
even though it might not be good you
could have a book by the time you
graduate because what if you're in
college right now when you get out and
you're starting a job you have way less
time even though you're not home work
it's a way of a way less time to sit
down and write so you could in theory
yeah that's that's knowing what you know
now back in college you know you didn't
know you had all that free time it's
like oh [ __ ] I got to finish this
assignment or there's this party or this
whatever that I got to do and and you
know all drama and stuff that goes with
it and you don't realize that once you
get out it's you're going to have a lot
more responsibilities and it's all on
you at that point but yeah so I don't
blame them if they don't have their [ __ ]
together and okay when they graduate
what's that book that came out years ago
the road warriors way the warriors
remember everybody was doing the
Warriors way way when I got into comedy
and when I got into comedy 91 I was just
a [ __ ] but in 94 and a half for some
reason I said that's it I have to
document all this yeah like I had no
books to write jokes in but I also took
and this is what I also did for writing
I also have now in Mike Allen and I've
always had this you have you look at you
candle this is January 1 through 30 and
alright but if you turn the page again
in the new count isn't how it has your
day and what time your appointments are
you okay yeah so I haven't this things I
have to do every day
I even made a log for writing yeah so
when I'm writing there's a notebook next
to me and I have the outline out and I
have how long I spend on it that's a
checkpoint every day like that really
helps getting into the groove yeah if
you want to get into the groove of
reading put it in your list you know I
have to go to the gym I gotta go to dr.
2:30 I'm doing a podcast with Joey at
5:00 and then 30 minutes a day before
Paula comes home rip out a book about
Tom Brady first of all start with [ __ ]
that you liked right yeah that that's
the number one thing don't read a book
cause some guy told unit just read a
book that you like when you when I go to
Barnes and Nobles I look for [ __ ] you
know and sometimes I go in there looking
for one thing and he ends up finding
this oh yes that that's all of them love
it love it love getting surprised yeah
love leaving there it's like a record
store or going in for you going in to
look for the Warriors but you find
[ __ ] a concert it's it's a surprise I
love just start with reading what you
enjoy you enjoy bad food rather chef
write a book read a book about a chef
with bad recipes a lizard lizard' me
yeah and then read a book about you like
New England you like we have the the Bob
legacy has given me a couple Patriots
books I have to read so I would love to
read them Bob willingness is the best
guy to give books nobody gets a better
book than Bob alingas some people are
like that yeah give me the Jimmy Page
biography got me the [ __ ] I think he
got me too no he didn't get me Peter
Grant he got me the Led Zeppelin book
there's one other one he got me that's
sensational
not the Hollywood Henderson one but the
one about the [ __ ] guy through the
Detroit Pistons
Marvin bad news bonds like these guy
yeah you know those reads for me that's
a day oh sure yeah I can read those the
dead and it's great fun and it's it's
something that you know you get into
your head and you it's a relaxing
experience but you also if you're trying
to write a book at the same time yeah
you can relax and have fun with it too
but you know if you have a pen with you
and you can you know underline you know
how
he introduces certain characters or how
he starts this chapter or you know how
you know he refers back to this point
and stuff like that you can kind of see
how the pieces all fit together it's it
can't be a good exercise to if you're
trying to write you know you can still
read for fun yeah but you can also get
something out of it
Joey's been asking a lot of questions
about like how how you like get a job
and all of that how much has this
changed in the last 5 or 10 years with
digital right because like I went like
Joey's coming with questions that I
think would have been a lot more complex
for you to answer maybe 15 years ago
what are you saying [ __ ] and I'm
asking the back question oh yeah that's
a great question yeah yeah well it's
it's really kind of opened up things in
two different directions that people
didn't anticipate and when it came out
you know when when the candle came out a
lot of people were we're kind of
building their their end-of-the-world
shelters and stuff like that like if
they thought it was going to end books
as we know it and you know that it's if
you look back you know they had that
same kind of panic when they started
doing paperbacks like cheap paperbacks
like oh this is gonna kill publishing
but you know the e-book is now just
another format some some people prefer
to read on a Kindle and be able to take
you know a thousand books with you
wherever you go or some people really
have to have that page that you that you
turn and you feel and and so it's some
it's just another segment of the market
and it's a different different types of
writing or better suited to digital than
others but at the same time it's just
gone to consumer preference you know
whoever likes reading paper versus
digital I like reading and the other
Taysom I I like having the book holder I
do both them but I really enjoyed
reading of the iPad yeah flight home I
really enjoyed that in fact I'm gonna
have more books and yeah because
everybody always says you exercise
routines and you have to down
yeah download them on that oh sure yes
thing in the world well and it depends
on how you know what situation you're in
what you're doing what kind of time you
need to fill and then you know that
could dictate what's best for you and
and sometimes it's good to you know open
your your mind to different methods like
just a few years ago I started really
getting into audiobooks one huh yeah
when I found myself you know doing most
of the cooking at home or doing most of
the driving and things like that and and
having this free time where my hands are
occupied and I have to focus on
something else
but I can also have an audio book going
and and some of the books are even
better that way like if you if you get
and get Stanhope's last book get it on
audio those let's do it oh he does it
several other P it's like his podcast
it's great and sometimes you know with
especially with memoirs where it's that
person reading it it's a different
experience you know I'm definitely
reading much yes yeah the scare that
should ever be absolutely that's gonna
be a party okay good time because we're
shoutouts real quick my man Jeff
McQueen's
Anthony's something the stonemason thank
you for your old Toma [ __ ] this guy
offered me a job as a stonemason so uh
so Mason Tony Zeo Tyler Howell Renee and
cost Fiona took a picture of [ __ ] the
[ __ ] I used to drink when I was a kid
that'll put 92 pounds on it's [ __ ]
condensed milk what are as usually and a
ton of sugar I forget what the [ __ ]
Dominicans call it but that shit's good
my man dude Aaron Michael Stein my man
Frankie Barker run a test plan in
Australia Kanye Twitter and Dave Wilder
thank you it was always a pleasure
seeing you in Austin again [ __ ]
and don't forget my 55th birthday show
February 17 7:30 at the ice house and
then February 23rd [ __ ] Lee and
myself invade the Denver Comedy Works
we're gonna be green chile nine times
in three days so I'll see you guys that
the comedy works those tickets are
posted already listen guys it's a I'm
doing clubs I'm not started do taters so
I still do clubs so it's the comedy
works I've been selling these tickets
get them quick if you want to see Mac I
don't add shows I'm too [ __ ] old
so Comedy Works February 23rd to the 26
to 72nd on the 24th 22nd to the 24th let
me get the Ice House on February 17th so
the main question is Joe Gordon Jordan
why don't you go in you do it I've been
called worse
I'm a college kid yeah one of these
degrees what do I do
I just graduated I got my [ __ ]
literature degree what's my next book
how do I make a [ __ ] living get a job
at Starbucks well you're right and
you're trying to do it to make a name
for yourself how do you make a name for
yourself already
it depends on what you're trying to
write if you if you're writing fiction
I say literary fiction write something I
start with you Ashley because I always
get confused oh that's right make sure
this [ __ ] right right fiction yeah
is [ __ ] and nonfiction on field is
not [ __ ] all right I gotta always
remember is real okay so if you make
[ __ ] up you have to get really good at
making up [ __ ] through short stories and
and sending those out for publication
you can just try and draft your novels
but I do highly recommend if you're
writing fiction especially a literary
fiction or somes onerous like science
fiction does a lot of short stories too
and mystery sometimes but you can you
know write those short pieces get a
little bit of a name for yourself and
then once you're finished with your book
your manuscript then you have a little
bit of a name to send out with that
we'll cover short what are you saying so
if if you're writing a novel then
sometimes it depending on the novel that
you're writing it helps to have short
stories published so there's a magazine
or whoever you're writing for that
prints short stories that has kind of at
that point given the stamp
approval of oh this is a good enough
writer for us to publish and there are
some of those magazines out there like
oh there's oh if you get into like like
a gargoyle or it depends on on what your
preference is the Los Angeles review is
one of my favorites and and there are
tons of of other options depending upon
what kind of stories you're writing and
this is something that that you writing
memoir you don't have to worry about but
if you're writing fiction if you want to
be the next Hemingway let's put it that
way then you've got to start writing
into these these magazines and and find
something that that connects with your
style and then you know build up a name
for yourself sometimes you can win
awards and then people start coming to
you I have one client who wrote a a
short story in a local literary magazine
not even a big publication and it got
nominated for a big award and it won and
and at that point we have you know
publishers calling me saying I want to
read whatever she has because we know
she's a good writer
and so we're working on on her book
right now but yeah that's that's
definitely one way to do it to kind of
give yourself a leg up make it a little
bit easier so it's just like humble you
go yeah job like anything else yeah you
got to pay the bills you can find
yourself you just write six seven hours
a day
yeah rough time yeah you got to find the
time it's the same [ __ ] struggle yeah
it's the same struggle and it's you know
you find the time you make it work there
I'm trying to remember the name of the
writing group I think it's the the four
am writing club or something like that
of people who wake up at 4:00 a.m.
because that's the only time that they
have they have families or they have
jobs and things that they have to take
care of but they can make some time out
for themselves at at 4:00 a.m. to put
down you know 500 words day or whatever
they do and and you just make it happen
I know good friend of mine Doug rice is
a novelist who wrote his second book
literally with a pen in one hand and his
baby daughter in his other hand and so
if you want it bad enough it's just like
comedy you got to find a way to make it
work you got to find a way to put the
time in
Wow I thought I had no [ __ ] idea that
you struggle that much I thought that
let's say I always thought like
freelance writers just wrote different
articles send them out
is there a living and freelance writing
I mean oh sure yeah that's a lot of
people make a good living that way and a
lot of a lot of novelists will also
write freelance to to supplement their
income and just whatever they need to do
to make it work they want to be a writer
then they're gonna be a writer you know
doesn't matter what they're writing for
as long as they're doing that you know
my my wife is a fashion writer I was
just gonna say loves to do for the og
listeners of the church when we first
started there was a girl living on my
couch yeah and she moved back to Boston
and now she's a technical writer so she
writes oh yes for websites to help them
with their SEO stuff and then she does
that all day every day
yeah blog writing manuals whatever you
need to do I mean there's everything
that you read has to be written by
someone and so you got find that job and
do what you need to do and then and then
you can in your spare time do whatever
you want if that's if you want to write
to pay the bills you can write to pay
the bills it's gonna be really hard but
let's work out there to be had what do
you look for when you sign a client do
you ever sign somebody rather college oh
sure yeah I mean even before that two we
had we had one author who is um she's
working on a new book now that first two
contracts she signed including a really
lucrative one had to be co-signed by her
parents because she was underage she was
I think 15 when we sold her first book
and seventeen when he sold her next or
something like that she's not my client
she's another at our agency but you know
sometimes people get a head start on it
like that and sometimes people come into
it late in life and it doesn't really
matter as long as they can deliver the
goods and I mean that's one of the
wonderful things about the digital age
yeah that you found that
fifteen-year-old girl that's amazing oh
yeah she found us just out to us but but
yeah at that point it's like oh we can
really we can really do something with
this
and one of the biggest changes when I
worked at another agency before I
started this one and one of the biggest
changes is the previous agency we would
sign a new contract for each book and I
saw that as being way too short-sighted
so instead of signing the book we signed
the author saying okay what do you want
to do for your career and then what kind
of long-term trajectory can we have you
on and we'll brainstorm different ideas
of you know write this one then write
that one and stuff like that and and
really make it make it work make an
investment in that person so most the
time almost always I'm looking for
someone who I can make an investment in
who is going to grow rather than just
one book that I can flip and you know
make a little bit of money I want more
than that
what uh what would somebody have to send
you to particularly your fancy to be an
author that they want to be represented
and would have to send you the
manuscript or yeah they it depends upon
the agent you're reaching out to you
have to be able to write a query letter
which is just a one page short bit about
the book short but about you and and
then whatever else they ask for like
yeah I I say if you're a fiction writer
I have this on my website and all agents
have this on their websites for for lit
they'll have exactly how you want
submissions so if you're writing novel
write me a career letter and paste in
the first chapter underneath so that I
can see what the book is about but I can
also see your writing style and if that
is something that catches me then I'll
ask for more or less for the whole thing
and read the whole manuscript and see
you know does this fall up how does this
fall apart or does this you know have
some potential and and it's different
for every agents so always go to the
agents website and check them out first
before you send but you will need to
have if you're writing fiction you'll
need to have the full book finished the
whole manuscript written out if you want
to write nonfiction then it's sold on
proposals so you don't have to write the
whole thing first but you need at least
one two three really good polished
sample chapters and then this
book proposal that's like a giant sales
document of you know what's all of your
your media experience how you're gonna
be able to sell books and and that kind
of stuff and and from there you know we
we go to you know working with this
person if we want to or on to the next
one if we don't so I just cuz I'm a
cynic you're a [ __ ] I'm gonna
caught that that too you're a lot of
things I'm too many things do you like
for people out there who are writing and
submitting and he not hearing back do do
agents and stuff really read those
submissions emails and land like and
they're so like it like sometimes you
feel like you're all I'm just wasting my
time throwing these in no one's ever
gonna see them but they like people
actually look at them
yes people actually look at them the
percentages of getting through or are
very slim and it depends on who you
submit to sometimes they have interns or
first readers or you know some people
you know sometimes a college kid is a
writing student who's looking to get
more experience you know will be trained
to be a first reader for submissions and
then the agent will then read after that
and stuff like that but I've I've always
read my own submissions because I'm a
bit of a control freak that way I don't
want to trust some kid who may or may
not know what it takes you know put in
that extra time to go through the inbox
and pick out you know what I see is
being good and and from there it's just
you know process of is this something
that can be edited is it's something
that is some you know what's the level
of success potential there is it a
subject that is that is come and gone
you know are you writing about you know
teenage vampires and stuff like that or
you writing something that hasn't been
done to death you know all these things
that we have to think about before we we
signed someone one of the biggest turn
offs when somebody sends you a package
like what it was the first thing you
look at that you just closed a package
and toss in the garbage well send me a
package would be one I'd that tend not
to open things that writers send to me
just randomly it's all through the email
these days very rarely are you gonna be
physically stuffing envelopes and
sending them out
so yeah I would walk them through your
[ __ ] office with the anti new script
because yeah who holds who I don't know
anything about you have someone helping
you out of the building at that point
but it's um that's actually it's a good
point because that's that's one of the
first things that we look for is do they
follow submission guidelines and so
we'll spell it out you know on our
website sometimes it's in guidebooks
that lists agents you know how to submit
to this agent and we are as open as we
can you know as open as possible about
that process of how do I want you to
submit to me and if say I were to ask
for send me your query letter in first
chapter and they send me a query letter
and first five chapters then I know that
very least they can't follow simple
directions you know I was and from there
you know it's like well what is the
editing process gonna be like and when
we have to have really in-depth you know
how to take care of this problem in the
manuscript before we could send it out
you know we have to go through that the
editing process and if they can't follow
simple directions and the submissions
then how can I trust that they're able
to do that I don't know that person you
know sometimes it's it's um it's not a
perfect process but we have to make
those assumptions that's it's a rough
world yeah I just you know for years I
just read books you know and then I
think it was the art the war of art got
me going and there was something else I
read and I finally started my myspace
thing and that was rough oh my god but I
really stuck to it yeah like I remember
being at the Dallas improv and [ __ ]
like being pissed cause I had work
Sunday night so I went out to the
hallway computer yeah I had to write my
blog on Facebook and the hallway
computer because I wanted it out by
Monday at 6:00 oh yeah and I outlined in
those days guys it would take me 12
hours to write 200 [ __ ] words
and I had [ __ ] misspelled but I knew I
was working a muscle yeah I really knew
myself that's when I came to the
conclusion that all those books are
[ __ ] nobody could teach you how to
write I could give you an outline on how
to write or what to write and but you
have to do the rest
oh yeah and then the hard writing push
me over on writing and then I heard like
stories about Mitch Hedberg I mean Mitch
Hedberg wouldn't answer his phone before
11:00 this was way before the drug use
he would lock everything up his girl
from left to work at 8:00 yeah so he
would write Tommy from 8:00 to 11:00 you
know and that's what it takes to be a
[ __ ] writer you have to sit down
avoid the distractions which is YouTube
Facebook and Twitter you know that's why
there's nothing on that computer and
some Netflix or that's right on that
little computer my wife got me and
should start writing up yeah it says
YouTube and all that [ __ ] I can't access
it yeah I'm stuck on the weekends that's
why I bring that computer I got Twitter
on my phone but I won't have it on
Facebook you know because I want to
commit that was gay part of it that was
and even today I had a rough morning but
I still wrote 200 words
oh sure I know it's because tomorrow I'm
gonna have a cancellation and I'll write
500 in the morning and then 800 at 7
o'clock when I have nothing to do that's
an asset and I'm happy that we met
online
I'm happy yeah you've been a great
writing mentor and I I'm happy that
you're in town and everything worked out
I could move the podcast you come on and
just talk about writing any other
questions you might have for the master
disaster brother I mean how do you cuz I
when Joey asked and how add similar
because we talked a lot about how actors
go through it and at least with
stand-ups they have an audience of one
or two people to see if the jokes are
working like hata yeah like what how do
you talk when you talk to a writer who's
three four or five years in and still
working at Starbucks like what do you
tell them to get like
some continue going or that just
self-motivation I know it's partially
self-motivation but yeah like if there's
any sort of silver lining or happy rain
but you can give it to a writer who's
half like in the struggle oh yeah
absolutely I mean again sometimes people
make it right away and sometimes it
takes them you know a long time before
they can really find that success
and so if you keep putting the work in
it's that's what you need to do it takes
different amount of time for different
people and there's no magic formula or
you know book that you have to follow
this you know XYZ steps and and you can
become a successful writer yeah it's
good to read those kind of resources but
you know you have to put the work in and
sometimes it takes a while and sometimes
it doesn't but if you want to be a
writer you know whether or not you're
getting published right right every
[ __ ] day my first real experience was
writing and I've been doing this for
since 1995 and that's what I said that
with calmly I learned that that notebook
that notebook that makes you accountable
yeah you know Weight Watchers works
because it makes you accountable right
you know I have this thing called the
jujitsu workbook yeah I ordered on
Amazon when I come home it makes me
accountable it makes me go in there
right what I did what I learned if I
drilled it if I got tapped what
techniques I used I had to do that with
everything now and yeah well I have it
to my writing my writing really changed
I have one notebook that has a sticker
of a devil on it and in there I have
nothing outlines for self and it's weird
that over the years I've like Desperate
Housewives Desperate Housewives was a
script a guy out on a shelf for ten
years he dusted it off one day he put
some adjustments and he sent it out she
used me and it became a huge show on ABC
that's kinda that's because this people
write things and they just keep adding
things throughout the years no I had it
for ten years they'll be sitting on it's
like get get shorty okay that was about
an author that got killed but he had
this script that
sensational his wife Bette Middler
wanted [ __ ] three million for this
script and there will be in town though
he added this [ __ ] that takes forever
you know I knew this I just wanted to
get the gift of sitting down every day
because that's the most important thing
if you're gonna be a writer yeah and
sometimes I said you know over the years
I would sit down and do that comedy
[ __ ] writing which is the guy in the
coffee shop drinking the coffee with the
pen in his mouth
thinking of what to write and then I
changed it all around yeah I get to the
coffee shop and I have two notebooks and
I write the story me and we went to
Austin last week it was hilarious
we went to [ __ ] pop at those we saw
the bread and while I'm writing that
story now a joke comes in yeah huh so
I'm never just sitting there I'm never
just sitting there you follow me I'm
always writing this story that I'm
writing ain't nobody ever gonna see it
doesn't matter I'm working the muscle
yeah there's a lot of that in books too
and it's it you got it you got to treat
it like a job you get a clock in you
gotta clock it every day you know and
that's that's how that works you know
you have to run you know make the time
and really at the end of the day only
you can quit you know you can write
forever whether or not you're getting
published you know if you want to keep
writing you know be stopping you you
know it's um it's something that yeah
you can get a little frustrated and
sometimes it's a little hard or you
you're not selling as many books as you
wanted to or your ranking is not where
you want it to be but you know you can
bring yourself out of any hole really
you know and and the first thing to do
is to just keep writing and sometimes if
you get shot down you know maybe the
next one will go we had a really
successful author actually again we just
sold a new series by her and it was her
first series that didn't sell way back
in the day and her next book was big New
York Times bestseller yeah
she kept writing she got shot down with
the first one and then the next one one
hit and really helped make her career
and she's written dozens of books after
that and now we came back to the first
concept and said okay now that you're a
better writer knowing what you know now
what can you do with this and it just
just sold for quite a bit of money and
she's going to be able to write those
books that she wanted to way back in the
day so um you know it's only you can tap
out you know now let's say you're a
writer aspiring writer you're uh you
know you're not struggling I mean you're
just down on your luck and I think you
got something good you ever see those
commercials that light for Christian
writers we're looking for stories are
they scams like all those eBook writing
things I mean some of them are some of
them aren't it depends on what you're
trying to get out of it sometimes it's
like you just need you know two hundred
dollars to pay a certain bill and
there's this you can submit to an
anthology that will pay you $200 and and
you don't then get writes the story
after that but you solved your problem
you know it's whatever you're trying to
do and I'm not going to say you know
turn that down unless you want to do
something else with that story you know
and it's it's your choice do you want do
you want to maybe you'll be able to
submit that to a magazine and maybe win
an award and launch your career or do
you really need $200 and I'm I'm fine
with you know people who need to write
to make a buck you know whether it's
doing that or it's getting a job
technical writing or whatever you need
to do you know that's if you want to be
a writer you can you can write one of
the top three books you would recommend
for an aspiring writer just top three
books that they don't have to waste
their money in a thousand [ __ ] books
get a notebook get the three books
Gordon tells you and get the right and
get the [ __ ] feather with the egg
[ __ ] into a free butcher man it
depends on there's so many out there
it's you know but it really depends on
on your
personality like I sent you the the war
of art for writers and that's not even
one of my clients you know that's just a
book that I know a great book guys it
was about yeah for writers completely
different than what we spoken about
before yeah read cover easy read very to
the [ __ ] point and that's what got me
in a thousand words a day yeah James
Scott Belen he knows his stuff what's
his name James Scott Bell he's written
several other books too and and
sometimes when you find a writer like
that who is able to connect with you and
and instruct you like other writing
books don't you know that's often times
they'll have another book you check out
see what else you wrote say if you wrote
a book on on setting and you're having
trouble with setting then you know you
know you can go to this guy and and
he'll help you out and sometimes these
people are also writing coaches who can
can work with you and help you to you
know fix up certain areas through your
writing if you need that sort of thing
and if you have the money to spend on
that again not everybody else needs to
do that but you know I would say if you
do find a book that connects with you
you see what else the other see what
else he has so he would be good on
writing you brought up is another good
one
and that's one that's just kind of
no-nonsense right
right to the heart of things he is he
will lay it out for you you know his
process what he went through and what he
found worked for him and you know take
all this with a grain of salt you know
when if someone is telling you how to
write its how how it worked for them and
they may have theories and things that
maybe they teach in class and and it's
something that they found out works so
it's a good thing that you're asking for
three because you know if you just go to
one then you'll get a very narrow view
of what works so you have to get three
yeah like I said you have to it's good
even with the biography I read three
biographies because I see three
different points of view and what was
important what point that author wanted
to get out there
yeah that's what you learned from
reading those typing works what's your
third right my third I could name drop a
client and help her sell some more books
Nina I'm here it's good with Nina Amir
has some writing books that are
fantastic with Nina Amir Amir yeah am i
R she she wrote a new book called
creative visualization for writers that
if you are not so much a reading learner
as you are like an active learner or a
visual learner that's kind of book that
you want to get because it's more of
more of exercises and drawing and making
lists and and it's very active you mark
up the book and you do a whole bunch of
different things and and that will help
you kind of you know connect to writing
that way if that's how you learn so um
you know that one's great and lamotte's
bird by bird is another one that's great
there's just so many that are out there
that you can find something that you'll
connect with and and at the very least
it'll be enlightening you'll get
someone's point of view of what works
for them and and help you out so that's
good so well people if you think of it
being a writer I hope this helped you
out though yeah
Gordon's helped me out he's a very
fascinating guy I would give you his
email but [ __ ] you you'll be tortured
with [ __ ] questions write a book and
get back to me and then I'll hook you up
with [ __ ] Gordon yeah by the Gordon I
want to thank you again for coming on
here some lighting you know I wanted to
ask these questions I want to ask for a
few people cuz there's a couple rides to
hit me up a question yeah I don't know
I'm lost I can't say yeah yeah you can
you can tell them what works for you but
you know they're going to have to find
out what works for them and and you know
the the the biggest thing that I could I
could give as far as like words of
wisdom or what-have-you is you know if
you want to write write don't worry so
much about how how other people are
going to perceive it or is it going to
get published or whatever there are many
reasons to write you know your memoir
for example
even if you don't want anyone else to
read it you know it's an experience it
helps you change it you learn stuff
about yourself and you know I I say you
know often at writers conferences and I
meet different aspiring writers that you
know everyone should write memoir even
though maybe not everyone should publish
it that's the truth right yeah you learn
a writing exercise anyway yeah one of
the first writing exercises Doug stand
oh yeah tall we would go he goes write a
story about yourself right destroy real
life oh yeah
and oh it was a brass back then I found
those years ago brother thank you very
much with no problem man you mean the
world to me my class you've inspired me
and I'm not gonna die till I write this
[ __ ] book if it kills me we'll get it
now
let me guess with shout outs real
quickly we'll get the [ __ ] out of here
we'll close with Tony Bennett and then
like that nobody gets their [ __ ]
feelings twisted up like I was telling
you in the beginning of the show home
delivery is food services are growing
but one of the best ones in the country
is definitely blue apron they're the
leading milk it delivery service in the
US and while many people know that well
what we do many don't know about the
types of meals you can cook with blue
apron okay we're you know just having
burgers for dinners you're making
shortbread burgers with a happy child
cheddar sauce on a pretzel bun you're
preparing seared steaks with thyme pan
sauce and mashed potatoes I mean this is
the type of meals you'll be and you'll
be learning how to cook which is the
most important thing in all under 45
minutes and without a trip to the
grocery store because their mission is
to make incredible home cooking
accessible to everybody and they
achieved this by supporting a more
sustainable food system setting the
highest standards for ingredients and
building a community of home chefs
now they offered three different meal
plans a two-person meal plan a family
meal plan and ready for this one our
wine plan six bottles of wine from
renown
renowned wine makers delivered monthly
Calissa
let's cut this [ __ ] let's cut to the
chase here Lee what
male oh my god I have three delicious
ones I can't wait to cook
I have steaks and steak and cheesy
mashed potatoes I have roasted chicken
and rosemary vegetables and then I have
middle-eastern baked chicken and rice
it's that can't wait to cook all three
look at the menu this month together
strip steak with potatoes spicy maple
collard green a steakhouse favorite
steak house favorite inspired with a
delicious twist a chili infused maple
syrup chili infused maple syrup with
incredible ingredients and chef designed
recipes Brewer blue apron lets you see
the power of the food that you can cook
all right another deliverer of
proportion of ingredients and step by
steps recipes right to your door the
menu changes every week based on what's
in season and is designed by blue aprons
in-house culinary team blue apron offers
12 new recipes each week 12 new recipes
and customers can pick 2 3 or 4 based on
what fits their schedule blue apron also
sends only non GMO ingredients with meat
and no added hormones okay now here's
the truth you don't learn how to cook
you're gonna learn how to save money but
most importantly you're gonna it's a
family you want your family to grow you
grow you cook together and everybody has
a good time some of the best parts of
your day happen over dinner so we want
you to share that perspective okay so
blue apron is taking care of the family
the church listeners buy $30 off your
first order if you visit blue apron
dot-com slash Joey
$30 off your first order so check out
this week's menu and get $30 off your
first blue apron order a blue apron calm
slash show you again blue apron calm
slash Joey blue apron a better way to
cook it's probably the best way to cook
right now if you're busy and if you got
a hectic life and if you want to eat
healthy and if you want to learn how to
cook blue aprons did way to go again
that's blue apron calm slash Joey a
better way to cook number two [ __ ]
it's time to get paid
it's Superbowl time the big game is here
it's time to cash in big and bet the
my bookie dot AG my bookie is the
industry-leading online sports book and
its players enjoy the fastest ready for
this fast its payouts in the business
when they win I would only recommend the
service that's been good to me and our
listeners that's why I urge you to make
your way to my bookie you know why you
win they pay no drama no hassles you're
wasting your time betting anywhere else
all right
you putting the betting with three
monkeys you leave enough you're gonna
get bet they even have an in-game live
betting so you can place a bet after the
kickoff did you hear that after the
kickoff so you got a hunch on who's
gonna win the coin toss or the Gatorade
or who's gonna score first or who's
gonna get off safety go to my bookie dot
AG join now and score free cash to place
your super-mo wager on the house right
now my bookie is giving away up to a
thousand dollars to every new player you
like Joey how ready sign up today to
score an instant 50% bonus on your first
deposit that's right if you join today
with a yardstick that's 100 bucks
you'll get 150 bankroll to play with use
promo code Church CH you are CH to
activate the offer right you played your
win you get paid my bookie thought AG
again I want to thank blue apron I want
to thank my boogie down AG and I want to
thank my main man riding mentor and dear
friends Gordon wanna it's been a great
podcast Lisa at I'll see you Wednesday
Gordon I'll see you [ __ ] whatever but
we always talk and I'm really happy you
got a chance to come on the show see our
office and partake with us on what we do
thank you for your advice and your
knowledge oh he is I will have a book
out for you [ __ ] by the end of
the year if Gordon [ __ ] wants it Lee
kick that mule we're just going to close
it Tony Bennett I'll see you guys
Wednesday night tip-top Magoo ready to
go don't forget February twenty seconds
to the twenty whatever the [ __ ]
comedy works Denver but my 55th birthday
party it's just an hour
comedy show is February 17th 7:30 at the
Ice House
I'll see you either those places if not
I'll see you Wednesday Thank You Gordon
Thank You Lee
stay black have a great [ __ ] day I
[Music]
wanna be